Ultimately, when it is all said and done,
it will not be what you own or how much money
you are worth that matters.
What will truly matter is what you have done
to earn what you own.
The lines often blur between what we have
done and what we own because what we own is
a tangible way to distinguish and believe
that what we have done has value.
If I do something and receive a certain amount
of money for it, then it is fair to assume
that what I did had value equal to the money
I received for it.
But this method of determining real value
in life is not always accurate.
Although it may be true that what I did had
monetary value, it is not necessarily true
that what I did had any personal value.
And it is just as important, if not more so,
to have personal interest in the things we
do in order to claim any real value in them.
It is very possible to own lots of things
and have lots of money but still do very little
in terms of creating pride, value, and contribution
in life.
And that is a very important distinction we
must make.
We live in a time where there is massive opportunity
to find creative value, interest, and fulfillment
in what we do for work.
Simultaneously, we also live in a time where
making money in meaningless roundabout ways
is easier than ever.
People are selling eBooks on how to write
and sell eBooks.
People are selling webinars on how to make
and sell webinars.
People are making YouTube channels, not for
the love of video creation, but for the sole
purpose of making money at any cost of quality
and authenticity.
This is not to single out those who participate
in any of these areas.
There are, and have previously been, endless
ways in which people make money only for the
sake of making money, void of personal interest
or fulfillment in what they do.
Anyone who works for a company that they do
not care about in a position that they do
not like.
And anyone who chooses to do things or follow
career paths that sacrifice their values,
interests, and passions solely out of the
desire and desperation for wealth are all
examples of feeble self-sacrifice
Surely life requires sacrifice, but when it
comes to making money, what is the right amount
of sacrifice?
Is it more important to make larger sums of
money?
Or is it more important to maintain integrity
and authenticity?
It is clear that there must be a balance,
but when we determine this balance for our
self, we must remember that what matters most
in life is what we do, not what we own.
The only things that will make us truly feel
alive are our experiences.
How honest we can remain to our self and those
we care about.
And how much we can contribute to what we
believe in and enjoy.
Of course we need to make money in order to
do these things, but we must ask ourselves
how much money is enough money, and how much
self is enough self?
Whatever balance it takes to ensure that you
will be able to look back and appreciate the
depth of your connection to life and know
that you never shortchanged yourself, is the
balance you must create.